un musée des maths vient d'ouvrir vous
l'aurez compris sur cette chaîne Youtube
les mathématiques sont partout elles
façonnent notre monde de manière
passionnante du langage secret de la
musique aux effets spéciaux de tes films
préférés rien n'échappe à leur emprise
alors pourquoi n'a-t-on jamais pensé à
mieux les mettre en valeur en France
justement la maison des mathématiques
répond à ce problème en vous montrant au
cours d'un voyage scientifique comment
elles interviennent dans notre quotidien
c'est l'occasion de découvrir nos
chercheurs et chercheuses ainsi que
leurs travaux de l'intelligence
artificielle à l'aéronautique en passant
par la lutte contre contre le cancer ils
apportent leur expertise dans toutes les
disciplines une façon très ludique d'en
apprendre plus sur le monde qui nous
entoure et sur les avancées des sciences
à travers les yeux des mathématiques on
y découvre aussi des grandes figures
comme jean- perérin le père fondateur du
CNRS ou encore la géométrie fractale
dont on a fait une vidéo sur le sujet un
espace en VR vous permet même de
découvrir comment des calculs et
résultats scientifiques peuvent prendre
forme je suis souvent dans les parages
donc peut-être qu'on s'y croisera mais
sachez